à la dure bien 7 kg par rentrer dans la
robe de marilyn l'avait acheté 1400
dollars aujourd'hui elle coûte 4 4
millions 8
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue au maître gala 2022 et sans
plus attendre découvrons tout de suite
les plus belles pièces de cette année
oui on commence par kendall jenner
ambiance sortie de lit en me to play
dans sa housse de couette oui pratique
pour se taper un petit dodo discretos
dans le van jj à 10 noeuds quand elles
porteraient pneus bas comme personne et
oui et notons d'ailleurs la couleur
rouge qui n'est pas sans rappeler la
fameuse sauce harissa non mais regardez
qui voit là une personne qui sort
directement de la bouche ah oui en effet
il fallait oser et que dire aussi de la
fameuse robe barbapapa ambiance fête
foraine bon et puis tenez regardez qui
nous sortent tout droit de la piscine
municipale là bas un et on me signale
que jared leto est venu accompagné à wii
2 qui tient de sa femme et non
accompagnés de lui-même bizarrement en
voilà un qui a sorti un costume qui ne
manque pas de pitot c'est la première
fois depuis des années qu'on a une
influence française avec lena situation
qui a été invité c'est quand même
exceptionnel elle était magnifique
j'adore les lingotins c'était pas mal on
parle d'une influence est énorme et
cyriac et influencer le café sensations
aussi c'est kim kardashian parce que tu
es une carnation à porter la robe que
marilyn porte et là on a là ni vers
nantes ou à regarder donc l'énorme
regarder l'ena elle était là alors là
oui kim kardashian c'est pas nul c'est
pas nul dans cette coiffure est alors
pour entrer comme qu'on ne peut pas
toucher à la dure bien 7 kg par est
entré dans l'arrondissement et la porter
avec des gants parce qu'elle sait une
pièce de collection maryline l'avait
acheté 1400 dollars aujourd'hui elle
coûte 4 4 millions 8 à la robe on a
remballé leurs collections et d'histoire
et avec blake lively
j'aime bien les clarifie pas mal mais
this way donc pas mon délire y'avait
kendall jenner
[Musique]
pas mon délire y
avait et les bieber la femme de zeus
trains
bondés lire
[Applaudissements]
la personne mais mon délire de
l'anaphore personne quel menteur
personnes bas je vous dis que je dis
jenner les rayons
street chic pas maintien sans nuances à
yahvé kourtney kardashian et travis
baker ouais ouais ouais
ouais comme
la sai on n'est pas là c'est parti trop
loin trop loin trop vite trop
alors trop de style
ça donne des indices pour les tendances
aussi fait valoir dans les cheveux
ébouriffés peut-être la barrette le kilt
oui oui c'est mieux que
moi c'est à dire l'autre par exemple
c'était l'autre c'est l'année prochaine
oui
corrigé au rythme
après l'annoncé tout le bouquin tout
est là d'ouvrir l'horizon trop longtemps
aussi du show officiellement interdite
aux émirats mais pourtant tolérée à
dubaï ap de cette ville la principale
destination en matière de tourisme
sexuel dernière polémique en date le
porte à poti gate ou le scandale des
escort girls considérés comme des wc
ambulante sur la vidéo qui circule cette
semaine on peut voir un homme faisant
kaka dans la bouche d'une femme
plusieurs blogueurs ont révélé sur leur
chaîne que certaines influences
s'adonneraient à des pratiques
scatophile pour assouvir le fantasme de
riches milliardaires tu faisais est ce
qu'on va manger kaka de gros monsieur
certaines d'entre elles pourrait
empocher jusqu'à 20000 euros pour subir
de telles humiliations physique en fait
tout a commencé il ya quatre mois c'est
un youtuber anglais qui a fait une vidéo
en disant que certaines jeunes femmes à
dubaï avait recours à ce genre de
pratiques my pour illustrer la vidéo il
a mis des photos regarder de deux
candidates française en l'occurrence les
jumelles el himer mais aussi mis la
jasse mines suite à ça il ya un blogueur
qui s'appelle aquabaie qui s'est emparée
de la sphère qui enquête depuis
longtemps sur les rumeurs de
prostitution dans la télé réalité entre
temps sur youtube et anglais a mis une
autre vidéo un commentaire pour dire que
ces photos en fait il les avait juste
mise pour illustrer le sujet et qui ne
les connaissais pas personnellement
d'accord là aujourd'hui c'est parole
contre parole les influenceurs en
question disent qu'elles vont attaquer
toutes les personnes bien sûr les
dénigrent lorsqu'elles sont victimes de
harcèlement et le blogueur ac aurait dit
lui qu'il a des preuves concrètes et
c'est ça qu'on attend des progrès at
elle été recrutés pour des soirées elles
ne savaient pas forcément que des
pratiques scabreuses ou délirantes
allait se produire elle arrivait dans
une chambre après avoir rendez vous avec
un milliardaire et elle se trouvait
souvent face à quatre hommes des gardes
du corps aient été forcés à des choses
et pour les forcer parfois elle était
droguée donc après il y avait
effectivement
défécation sur elle
forcé à manger leur vomi des rapports
sexuels avec des animaux non et le chant
et le chantage c'est le chantage c'était
drogue et ont confisqué les papiers ont
leur confisquer leurs papiers kg que
nous en tant que candidate de télé on
reçoit souvent des propositions qui sont
assez avec des sommes assez
astronomiques ça c'est vrai ça nous un
jour quoi car on reçoit des trucs titre
ça ne pourra envoyer des photos des
photos de pied ou pour d'autres pays oui
j'ai reçu des diamants j'ai déjà reçu
des propositions jusqu'à 5000 euros pour
une photo de pie xi s'impose 5 euros
pour les matchs donc savourer yade et
rachida ou pour mon pays dans la gueule
5000 euros pour une faute de pied on va
demander des photos dénudées aussi oui
ça ça on reçoit tout le temps
effectivement de l'écran vous qui ont
votre combien savent arrive ça varie en
fonction du physique de la personne je
suis pas ce genre de prix doivent être
bas mais non mehdi minne 10000 rouge
ouais ça peut aller c'est normal et
jusqu'à 50 millions s'il ya déjà des
copines à vous qui sont posés la
question qui sont ni c'est vrai que
c'est énormément d'argent est-ce que je
ne vais pas un délai assez bien notre
vie justement pourquoi avoir à se la
poser cette question même s'il voit
quand même temps malgré tout
le mal que tu accompagnes quelqu'un pour
cinquante six mille euros la semaine je
reconnais que tu peux te dire quand et
jusqu'où alors le mail on peut pas voir
le meilleur ici voilà et de metz et tu
te dis si tu es une jeune fille s'était
juste cogné un milliardaire dîner avait
mille balles je venais en glace et ma
famille
c'est en anglais les montants sur la fin
on paye 8000 euros par jour ouais c'est
incroyable will give you et oh mios
56000 pour la semaine ouais placettes et
ils disent quoi il dit c'est quoi pour
accompagner à accompagner les efforts
des bauges al arab voilà alors là c'est
ça ouais là oui c'est ça ou ils mettent
aux réservations feuilles ou une suite
burj al arab c'est incroyable réseau ça
commence à être précis rendez vous
attendu le sujet vous avez besoin d'un
chauffeur ouais quand vous me conseiller
un chauffeur avec une luxueuse voiture
pour cinq ans et vous êtes payé ça
continue il a dit sur l'histoire du
passeport c'est là que les filles
doivent faire attention parce que une
fois que tu es là bas tu es foutu en
comparaison gilles petit peu dit il peut
il peut attester ce que je dis il ya
quinze ans des footballeurs
professionnels étaient au début quand
ils sont partis jouer à dubaï pour
l'argent les présidents de clubs
prenaient leur passeport et dites vous
bien qu'un mec un footballeur
professionnel
ils étaient bloqués à dubaï il pouvait
pas partir les footballeurs renommée
j'avais joué en ligue 1 qui était connue
ils étaient bloqués là-bas ils pouvaient
pas partir même d'émettre qu'on joue en
équipe de france dont il faut dire aux
filles faut pas partir là bas comme sa
tête baissée en disant je vais aller
prendre deux cent mille euros en en un
mois parce que si tu prennes le
passeport c'est terminé t'es dans la
merde
[Musique]
depuis quelques mois plusieurs clients
ont déposé plainte après avoir été
étrangement piqué par des seringues et
j'ai senti vraiment une piqûre sur
l'épaule des piqûres sauvage qui
provoque souvent malaises vomissements
il parfois amnésie craintes très mal
dont les gens ont lâché je suis tombé
par terre à rennes toulouse ou béziers
une cinquantaine de plaintes ont déjà
été recensés alors que des analyses
toxicologiques sont actuellement en
cours tu me demande toujours ce qu'ils
ont pu injecter pour que les médecins
n'arrivent pas à décoller c'est un truc
de fou alors juste sarah merci d'être là
vous c'était lors d'un festival
qu'est ce qui s'est passé mais en fait
on était dans un événement donc entre
étudiants et du coup cet événement il
durait sur trois jours donc toute la
journée c'était des sports et le sort
s'était plutôt festif donc il faut
savoir qu'ils avaient beaucoup d'alcool
mais vous moi j'en ai pas forcément pris
le problème c'est que pendant ces trois
jours là j'ai pas du tout dormi je me
sentais enfin un peu pas dans mon état
normal donc j'étais désinhibé j'étais un
pays hyper active encore donc comparé à
mes copines mais mais mais mais mais là
me disait fin était arrivé quelque chose
tu appris quelque chose alors que non et
justement le dernier jour un ami à moi
il s'est aperçu que j'avais une trace
donc sur le bras donc entouré d'un bleu
et du tout en fait je me suis dit que
c'était peut-être un insecte une psy
coup sûr le soir parce que forcément on
ne pense pas tout de suite à ça donc dès
que je suis rentré je me sentais
vraiment très très mal donc dès que je
dormais j'avais des sueurs froides donc
j'ai contacté un médecin j'ai demandé ce
que c'était ce que ça pouvait être et il
m'a dit clairement ça c'était pas du
tout insecte que c'était une piqûre donc
suite à ça j'ai fait beaucoup d'examens
j'étais vraiment très paniqué je suis
toujours parce que du coup les examens
toxicologiques qui révèle à rien tout de
suite à ça j'ai demandé à mon groupe
d'amis donc qui était tout le temps avec
moi si je n'avais pas quelque chose et
là bas un autre ami à moi donc il ya un
garçon pourtant on peut croire que ça
touche que les femmes mais non non non
il a eu aussi la même figure aussi au
niveau du bois du roy c'est un fléau en
manque assez d'informations aujourd'hui
quoi et donc vous avez eu un cas qu'est
ce qui s'est passé en d1 qu'à une fille
qu'on connaissait d'une soirée étudiante
qui revenu vers nous
six jours je pense après les faits on
l'a tout de suite conseillé d'aller
porter plainte pour connu on puisse lui
donner accès aux vidéos elle raconte
qu'elle avait une piqûre après oui elle
sera rendue compte deux ou trois jours
après mais elle a pas eu d'effet très
grave à la quitter le club
récupéré par ses amis après la très
bonne nouvelle que je vais vous donner
c'est qu'au moment où on parle les
auteurs sont identifiés
un scoop pour tous pas mon poste donc
voilà ce qui s'est passé ça a commencé
dans la région de grenoble de boîte de
nuit avec notamment une soirée étudiante
plusieurs centaines de personnes les
victimes viennent se plaindre au
commissariat et quelques semaines et la
police tout de suite prend la mesure du
phénomène est un défi entre jeunes sur
un réseau social que je ne cite pas et
j'ai vu des images de ces jeunes qui se
félicite entre eux ils sont deux auteurs
principaux il se félicite entre en
s'envoyant des seringues quand ils ont
piqué tiens j'ai piqué et il s'envoie
des sorins avec vous savez le chiffre
et d'après les premières analyses
toxicologiques cela corrobore ce que
vous dites pour le moment aucune
substance toxique
il n'est revenu c'est à dire que pour le
moment il n'y a rien dans les seringue
et après et après ces jeunes là voilà se
félicitait voilà on en a eu dix on en a
eu 2 j'en ai eu trois et c'est
ahurissant il faut se dire que peut-être
il faut pas rester seul en boîte c'est
peut-être ça le message clé c'est qu'il
faut pas être seul si jamais vous sentez
une piqûre vous donner quelques conseils
très simple tout de suite allé voir
quelqu'un ne restez pas tout seuls dans
votre coin ne visite pas au y avait
peut-être quelque chose regarder
immédiatement puisque la réaction locale
elle va arriver quasiment immédiat
wynants ainsi je vous prends une
aiguille et je vous la pique vous allez
avoir un petit bleu vous allez avoir mal
et vous à voir qui va se passer quelque
chose et ensuite la démarche à faire
c'est d'aller immédiatement aux urgences
aux urgences ont offert une prise de
sang on va vous faire un test urinaire
puisque le ghb on parle que de ça mais a
certainement d'autres toxiques il va
rester dans le sens que quelques heures
12 heures dans les urines mais on peut
leur chercher dans les cheveux durant
quatre semaines mais pour ça il faut
porter plainte quelques années seringue
en elle-même qui piquent plusieurs fois
peuvent devenir toxiques
même s il a notamment dans une des
régions qu'on a cité il ya un trafic de
seringue que les jeunes seraient partis
c'est après ça ça peut être dangereux
c'est vrai que si vous êtes piqué une
première fois à y est que vous repiquer
quelqu'un d'autre et puis quelqu'un
d'autre et le garder la même seringue
pendant trois semaines effectivement il
ya peut-être à risque néanmoins le
risque est globalement on n'est pas en
paix et en épidémie de vih et les gens
qui ont le vih sont comme les autres ils
ont une vie normale la plupart du temps
ils sont bien équilibrées par leur
traitement ils ne sont plus contagieux
pour les autres donc ya pas de risque a
priori à ce niveau là alors encore une
fois proche de zéro ne veut pas dire
zéro mais effectivement très
certainement que la seringue ils vont
les utiliser une fois deux fois trois
fois je les vois pas utilisé comme chez
le médecin une tringle à usage unique
l'astérisque nettoyer désinfecter donc
non donc là on rentre effectivement dans
un peut-être un autre type de problème
manifestation qui à certains endroits
ont dégénéré arikat jets de projectiles
et vitrines endommager
le ministre de l'intérieur gérald
darmanin a dénoncé des violences
inacceptables
il ya eu des personnes manifestement des
casseurs qui étaient là pour mettre fin
à ce droit de manifester au total huit
policiers banques et blessé 45
interpellations les manifestants sont
ils allés trop loin lors des
manifestations du 1er mai
voilà alors voilà donc cesser votre
compagne et alexandre
c'est vrai que ça c'est ça a été une
image on s'est tous dit c'est
inadmissible de voir ça qui ce faisant
penser voyez pas attaqué ouais l'image
même les faits les gestes on peut pas ne
pas pardonner
sachez que moi même je suis pas je suis
pas d'accord par rapport à tout ça
surtout que les pompiers on en a eu
souvent besoin dans nos mobilisations
depuis pratiquement quatre ans
maintenant ça a été nos sauveurs dans
les minutes
parce que des fois on a eu des marchés
on a eu des yeux donc ça a été quand
même
ou est-ce que nos héros du moment jeudi
m c'est vrai que nous on nous a souvent
défendu ici dans cette émission et voilà
on comprend la colère de certains
français et des combes les pompiers
aussi comprennent voilà la colère de sa
pensée qui n'en peuvent plus et qui se
retrouvent dans des situations
inextricables et qui se retrouveront les
10 choses souvent cette expression le 10
du mois sans rien et qui se disent ya
une injustice incroyable et on allait
les gilet jaune notamment et où le
mouvement des gilets jaunes mais c'est
vrai que là elle l'agression de deux de
ses pompiers pourquoi pourquoi elle a
fait ça en fait c'était qu'est ce
qu'elle vous avez anémie à une personne
qui a été vers les pompiers au départ
mais normalement c'est une personne
aussi dans toutes les manifestations
quand les manifestants se prennent un
peu la tête avec les forces de l'ordre
est souvent là pour temporiser les
choses d'un côté comme de l'autre
d'ailleurs et laly a été au départ et on
n'a pas compris d'ailleurs le
raisonnement parce que c'est pas la
personne qui a réagi comme ça
normalement manifestation il ya en plus
qu'à l'habitude de travailler d'ailleurs
avec les pompiers parce que elle et
medic
moi même je ne comprends pas elle-même à
cette heure ci je pense qu'elle doit pas
ne pas comprendre ce qu'elle a fait non
permanente ça montre clairement que
naudin nos services publics sont
vulnérables et qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas cela que l'on veut aujourd'hui la
république c'est nous c'est pas lui lui
ou l'autre c'est nous ce sont l'ensemble
des services publics que ce soit les
forces de secours et forces de sécurité
l'ensemble de tous les services
administratifs qui au quotidien
subissent malencontreusement on va dire
tout simplement cessé acte complètement
volontaire de ces personnes qui agresse
en permanence et aujourd'hui on ne
souhaite plus de ça parce que pourquoi
parce que peut-être qu'on est gratuit
j'en sais rien parce qu'on porte secours
parce qu'on est tous vulnérables
aujourd'hui on ne veut plus laisser
passer ce genre de choses là donc
clairement aujourd'hui aussi une chose
qui est effroyable c'est qu'on regarde
tout le monde cette action-là ecotour
que des téléphones portables une
personne vient soustraire la carte sim
et cette culture là la sécurité civile
de dire je vais venir porter secours à
celui qui nous porte secours c'est même
pas venu à l'esprit qu'il allait faire
filmer et donc ça c'est pas tous les
rats non plus ça prouve que quelque part
on a aussi ce manque de culture et
d'approché de protection civile en nous
au sein de l'état français est
clairement aujourd'hui c'est une notion
qui doit être interministériel is et le
gestuel
et les bribes après moi je m'en excuse
je pense que s'il ya peu un jour venir
sur le plateau j'espère qu'elle pourra
pour s'en excuser la hausse il vienne
vraiment parce que je sais qu'elle fera
je connais son fond je sais comme harley
et
y'a pas grand chose à dire par rapport à
ça
le nord des landes été condamné à la
perpétuité pour le meurtre de la jeune
et lisse et jurés ont suivi les
réquisitions de l'avocat général
condamnation à la perpétuité
22 ans ferme
compressibles
depuis il est incarcéré à la prison de
saint-quentin-fallavier en isère pour
purger sa peine le centre pénitentiaire
à monde hors du monde jeudi dernier il a
été surpris pas les surveillants en
plein ébat sexuel au parloir de la
prison avec une femme qui lui rendait
visite pour la première fois une femme
avec qui nordahl aurait entretenu une
correspondance avant qu'elle fasse les
démarches pour obtenir un droit de
visite
alors on est dans un état de droit et
dans un état de droit c'est évidemment
très fort est incroyable que des
terroristes des pédocriminels des serial
killers et droit des avocats pour les
défendre ok mais après moi aujourd'hui à
titre personnel de mère de famille a
bien sûr insupportable mais insultants à
l'égard j'ose même pas imaginer les
parents s'aimaient mais ça m'est
insupportable d'entendre que normal
landais peu à voir de près ou de loin
une vie qui ressemble à une certaine
normalité je ne veux pas qu'ils prennent
du plaisir je ne pas qu'il se fasse
comme vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
c'est inaudible je ne peux pas longtemps
je sais qu'il a le droit je sais que
c'est possible mais je vois là je veux
je veux que la schl à la loi change il
faut savoir que nordahl le landais ça va
surprendre beaucoup de gens reçoit
énormément de courriers féminin il ya
beaucoup de femmes qui a envie
d'entretenir une relation était folle
nom des femmes
ce que disent tous les genres sont les
raisons
c'est trop simple de rire ces femmes à
des
bâches et pourquoi pas d'accord et qu'il
y ait ce qui choque c'est que c'était un
paroisse normal c'est pas un parloir de
vie familiale vous avez le droit de
faire l'amour c'est normal mais légale
sous ce nom là bas non à l'annoncé des
dates du tout les gars là on va plus
revenir juste lui va être condamné à
quatorze jours de mitard très
vraisemblablement ans et demi a guidé
ses bras comme ça et les gardiens sont
très vite intervenus dans qu'il essaiera
loi même dans la prison bien qu'il ai
raccompagné ce qui choque énormément
c'est que ça remet sur le tapis les
privilèges dont qui jouirait en prison
que j'avais on en a parlé j'ai
l'impression que ceux qui veulent lui
interdire les visites veut l'empêcher de
livres tout prix
il faut pas faire l'amour déjà tout ça
alors il
a pris la prison à perpétuité d'accord
il a quand même le droit je ne parle pas
de relation sexuelle qu'il a eue et de
subvenir à ses besoins primaires de
manger de respirer de dormir mais déjà
il a eu à mélangez pas tout il a eu un
rapport consenti avec une femme majeure
je ne pense pas qu'il doit être
interdite de visite pour ça si c'est
quoi c'est la peine de mort ou l'enfer
dans un trou il fait plus rire mais
autant que tu es et c'est inhumain
[ __ ] j'y sa mère avaler le voir c'est
sur ces jeux sont elles à calais le voir
si maintenant il ya d'autres gens ils
ont envie d'aller voir un mec qui a tué
une gamine de 7 ans café des actes
sexuels avec une gamine de 16 ans c'est
leur mort a tué leur moral pour moi ces
gens là c'est des bars pour mars et ils
sont comme lui c'est par elle la nana
qui envoyait les le téléphone pour
nyrstar l'amour avec un mec qui a reçu
une gamine de 7 en raison la prison
avait fui été commis et tu vaux rien du
tout et ses peines
m
non mais donc vous êtes pour la peine de
mort mais moi je moi je te dis qu'on
regarde je regarde je redis encore
n'avait pas forcé mec là qu'est ce que
je vais me prendre la tête à lui donne à
manger en prison qu'est ce que je vais
me
jeter il désapprouve ses émotions j'ai
que voilà et que quand ça vous dit ça
revient à instaurer la peine de mort et
que la peine de mort c'est profondément
inhumain mais le bagne de cayenne des
travaux
oui monsieur non ce qu'il a fait lui
c'est humain sinon oui ce qui l'a fait
redescendre et on ordonne le landais
jeudi ce qu'il fait c'est ce qu'il a
fait c'est atroce voyage je dis qu'on
aimerait non répond pas il faut croire
ils ont répondu à la barbarie parade en
soirée magie j'ai deux enfants mon jeu
et maintenant ils sont grands ils
peuvent arriver il peut arriver un
malheur quand même c'est ton style ça ma
fille j'ai pu de vie moi c'est fini tu
oublies madame ans je me lève pas le
matin par fr guinée avec mon camion je
cherche le m mais sept ans et c'est pour
ça que c'est une justice et que eric
léser
justice regarde la justice il fait elles
n'ont pas de réseaux sociaux une meuf
lama fabien harran dans la prison ils
tiennent la main faire ça c'est dur
comprends ta colère
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]